oh
why hello there i didn't know you'd be
there i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for
thursday july 8 20
21 as i like to do up top a quick
reminder to subscribe to our youtube
channel
tap that notification bell and do me a
different favor
this time i know i like to ask a lot of
favors of you guys and you usually come
through for me
but i spoke to our youtube uh contact
and i was saying how i get all of these
emails and people tweeting at me all the
time and facebook messages
of people that are subscribed to our
channel and don't see our videos in
their feed or they're never alerted of
our videos etc etc
and they always want the actual name of
the youtube account so
if you are watching this on youtube and
you want to comment
in the youtube section whether you're
seeing our videos
whether you're subscribed whether you've
tapped the notification about what other
whatever
information you can give us i can then
send that to our youtube person and
maybe they can
figure out why it is that youtube isn't
showing a certain amount of our
subscribers
these videos i can't imagine why but
perhaps
with the right evidence we might be able
to figure it out
all right guys we are doing a q a today
we got a ton of questions at
reubenreport.locals.com but before
we get to all of that i'm going to be
doing a story on joy reads she's
completely insane
she's a host over at msnbc which is sort
of a mental institution
of a uh cable news network and
uh and then we're going to get to some
questions and they're a good mix we've
got some politics some culture
some personal some other stuff so we're
gonna do all that but before we do i
wanna talk to you about bonner
private wine i've got a malbec in my
hand right now
if you're a health conscious red wine
lover like me here's how to make your
next drink
10 times healthier down in argentina
they make this really
dark red wine from malbec grapes grown
at 9 000 feet
they've lab tested these wines and found
that they contain up to
10 times the levels of longevity
and heart healthy nutrient called
resveratrol
resveratrol's powerful stuff it pops up
again and again in studies on longevity
heart health and brain health these
wines also have 90
percent less sugar fewer chemicals fewer
additives plus if you love steak and bbq
like i do
red wine has been shown to actually make
red meat healthier
but the best thing about these wines is
that they taste great with notes of
blackberry leather cherry and smoke i
mean it truly is darker just interesting
to look at
if nothing else today the guys at
freethinkerwine.com are giving you 50
off their best malbecs and you will also
get 50 off shipping wine makes a great
gift
even if it's just a gift to yourself
just visit freethinkerwine.com today
that's freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me all right let's talk
about joy reid you know this goes to
my sort of ethical philosophical debate
of how
often do we have to talk about the crazy
people right i you know i'm interested
in building things
i want to talk about good ideas the
right ideas i want to talk about how we
get out of this mess and yet there is
this huge segment of society that is
obsessed
with race and critical race theory and
they're obsessed with marxism and
communism and all the
bad time-tested ideas of generations
and on one hand it's like we should just
let them be let them have what they've
got
and just ignore them right like i think
there's a real argument there and then
on the other hand we need to sort of
expose them because we don't want
them to continue to brainwash people and
we need to have the tools right
uh so that we can combat their bad ideas
and also their bad ideas
are constantly ideas that are
encroaching on us right like if i was
in charge of the world i'm not and i
don't want to be but if i was in charge
of the world
i would be setting up a system that
basically just keeps everybody
sort of independent of each other you
figure out what associations you want to
have
and you can't just have other people's
stuff and you can't brainwash other
people's children's and things like that
the problem is that these guys it's not
that they want to be left alone they
want to control everybody so we got a
real problem here so i had to show you
this clip
of joy read i mean this woman really is
bananas and chris ruffo
who obviously i mentioned on the show
quite often great lawyer who's been one
of the lead
uh i would say proponents of the uh
the basically the destruction of
critical race theory because it does
feel like it's on the ropes a little bit
right now
um he's been on her show and and really
handed it to her a week or two ago
uh but now they're going deeper they're
going deeper because they know they've
sort of been exposed like i think that
the average person who's paying
attention to this stuff
is starting to realize that critical
race theory is racist
right the idea that you know a white kid
just born white
is somehow evil right and that these
things i mean we talk about this all the
time but that these things
that we know are good that like are
objectively good things like being on
time working hard
knowing basic truths like two plus two
equals four et cetera et cetera that
these are somehow
tools of white supremacy right and that
the founding of america
was evil okay you guys get all that
stuff already at this point well i think
we've done such a nice job exposing some
of this nonsense
that people like joy reid who are trying
to inject this into the system who are
trying to brainwash our children who are
trying to burn
the whole thing down who are not proud
to be americans i don't know what
they're doing here at this point
they're going deeper it's not just about
critical race theory anymore
now we've got to link it to q anon and
white supremacy in a deeper way and
trump and everything else
take a look because republicans aren't
running an election
they're waging an all-out war for power
that increasingly is based on and
steeped in the trump cult
and even white nationalism and no matter
how reckless and dangerous that is
they're doing it
believing it will move white voters
look no further than the ongoing
hysteria over
race conscious education what they are
shamelessly and falsely misrepresenting
as critical race theory radicalized
parent activists across the country are
targeting school boards
with behind the scenes help from
conservative groups
protesters are swarming those meetings
vowing to revolt
against a curriculum they've labeled
unacceptable and reverse
racist and leading the charge in this
fight is you guessed it
right-wing media yesterday fox news
mentioned critical race there are more
than
100 times before to before 1pm
before 2pm i should say all right so
just to be clear i mean joy reid
is a racist right she's just an
anti-white racist um
i don't think that's reverse racism if
you don't like people because of the
color of their skin
you're a racist she's a racist all right
so let's just put that aside
um she says something that's quite
extraordinary there radicalized parents
are targeting school boards
radicalized parents parents who actually
want to be involved in their children's
education who want to make sure that we
teach things like equality and a fair
assessment of history
their new line here is that somehow
conservatives and trump people and white
supremacists and q and i people
that they don't want any sort of honest
assessment of america to be taught that
we don't want
anything taught about race or the
history of america
or slavery or anything like that
complete
nonsense lies absolute
lies okay it's just crazy the idea that
it's radicalized parents targeting
school boards
these are parents who are trying to
de-radicalize
the schools but she knows that and all
she's got is her echo chamber of lies
and the tough part of this
is so now i can say that about her and
it's like all right
do i sway anybody i know that you guys
make sense of it but but now it's sort
of
it's sort of on you right like if you
have a friend that is watching joy read
like should you be slipping medication
in their drink in the morning
you know that might be one way of
dealing with it should we be
institutionalizing these people
like what do we what do we really do
about it now i get it not a lot of
people are watching msnbc and that's
sort of why they're more hysterical
all of the time but this is a serious
problem
she of course called refers to it as the
trump cult and white nationalism
i just want to go on the record as
saying one more time i went to many
trump rallies i never met a white
nationalist i never met a racist there
were gay flags
there were flags of every country there
were jews and muslims and christians and
latinos and blacks
and basically everybody there it was it
was a group of people that was pretty
much just sick of the swamp
and sick of the system all these people
have are
these ridiculous labels of calling the
rest of us white supremacists and
everything else
please show me the leader in america of
the white supremacist movement right
like really show me that person who is
the person
that wants white people to have special
treatment white people to have special
laws
now there are plenty of people that want
black people to have those things those
are the critical race theorists much
like joy reid
but it simply does not exist
i think you could make a very solid
argument that white christians in
america
are probably the least racist people
possibly in the history of the world
right as a majority of this country they
have
uh i don't want to say allowed it's not
it's allowed it isn't even the fair word
they have they have helped build a
country
and sustain the ideas that have allowed
everyone to come here
and everyone still wants to come and as
i always say
nobody wants to leave notice joy doesn't
want to go anywhere right like if it's
so terrible
why don't you guys get going i will
start a gofundme
progressives to leave america with a
parting gift
like let's raise a couple million bucks
i will do it i will do it
anyway it's dangerous stuff and we have
to keep exposing it
i sort of just see no way around it
before we get to the q a guys i want to
talk to you guys about start mail you
know
data breaches are at an all-time high as
hackers become more advanced than their
cyber security
attacks although joe biden did tell
putin there are 16 or 12 things that
he's not allowed to attack but besides
that you can do what you got to do
vlad uh and email possesses the highest
risk to identify
theft and credit card fraud among other
life-altering scams today hackers can
access sell or compromise anything from
your business plans
to your medical records which is why we
need to be concerned about our data
breaches
without proper email protection just one
data breach could change your life
that's why i suggest you use start mail
start mail keeps your email
private period every email can be
encrypted or protected with a password
which means hackers in big tech can't
read scan analyze or sell your personal
information
ever when you delete an email in start
mail it's gone forever another reason to
feel safe using start mail is because
it's backed by the world's most robust
privacy laws and start mail uses their
own servers not amazon's which means
they can't be put out of business like
parlor you also get unlimited anonymous
alias addresses
let's say you need pri to provide an
email to a company but want to protect
your identity
start mail can generate a shareable
alias email and they can be deleted
anytime
as you know i'm always saying that we
should be building alternatives to what
big tech is currently offering
which is why i respect how start mail
supports my privacy values
and will support yours too start
securing your email
privacy with start mail sign up today
and you'll get fifty percent off your
first year
go to start mail.com ruben that's start
mail with the t
s-t-a-r-t mail.com ruben for fifty
percent off your first year
startmail.com reuben and now back to me
all right
reubenreport.locals.com q
a you sent in a lot of questions phoenix
selected them for us he's our intern
i said pick good ones and i believe
that's what he's done here we go
alexa says as a teacher how do i combat
the crt narrative when i'm surrounded by
blue and on
in california well i would have two
answers here one would be if you were in
a decent state like florida
or texas or tennessee and then one is if
you're in a place like new york or
california
it's much more difficult so you were
here in california first off
good luck with everything um and
secondly
uh what what can you do well look i
would say you have to fight it at
every level possible if you are being
handed
curriculum from the teachers unions or
from the principal of your school or the
department head or whoever it is
and they're handing you stuff and
they're saying teach this to the kids
teach the kids that the 16-19 project
is really what the founding of america
is all about not 1776.
that race is the most important thing
that certain people have
privilege based on their race and the
color of their skin and their gender
and that family doesn't matter the
nuclear family doesn't matter and that
empirical facts don't matter and all of
those things and that
that if you get some a question wrong
but you're of a certain color you should
still get a good grade
all of the nonsense that is being
injected into the system right i don't
have to tell you
you're a teacher you know it it's like
you have to decide whether you want to
teach it or not
and i hate to say it but maybe you don't
want to teach it like i would say you
have to fight it like
you have to because if you are a teacher
and you know it's the wrong thing to
teach and you still do it it's like
at the end of the day like what are you
as a human and i don't mean that to you
specifically
but what are what are any of us if we
all just go along
with the lies right like what what are
we as people like we're all just on the
slow descent to hell together and i
guess it's nice that we're on the ride
together
but the end of this ride ain't good so i
would say
if you're a teacher and you're behind
being handed this stuff push back
against the administration as much as
possible
and if it becomes untenable i mean if
they mob you if they threaten you
whatever if they suspend you whatever it
is i would say look for another job so
i'm guessing that you're a public school
teacher
but find some private schools or
some charter schools that you could
apply at and there are some better ones
by the way if you're in california
there's not a ton of them i have many
many friends with kids
that are at elite schools here that are
being completely infected by this stuff
too so that
it's not an easy answer and i get it it
kind of sucks it's like nobody wants to
be the person that's standing up
but but maybe you do actually at the end
of the day right like at the end of life
like maybe you do want to be the guy
that was like yeah i said enough is
enough
giselle says i have a 17 year old that
is unsure what to do after graduation
and i'm torn about how to guide her
what advice would you give a high school
student about their future you know i
get
this question often when i go to
colleges or i do other events where
there's high school students whatever it
might be
um look i think there is some utility to
college like i look back
fondly on my college experience i got i
went to suny binghamton state university
new york at binghamton it's a it's a
pretty solid
sunni school pretty solid public school
okay
um now that was 20 something years ago
so
i know actually that it's been infected
by the social justice stuff and
everything else
but i did get a pretty decent education
i would say they're probably not great
and i probably i definitely could have
worked harder and i probably smoked too
much pot and played too much
too many video games and all that stuff
but i think there is a utility of
college meaning getting a more robust
uh set of ideas hopefully if you're at a
decent school and really more than
anything else the socialization part
like
that there should be some period of life
between say when you're in high school
living with your parents and you
you don't have like a vitally important
job you know maybe you have an
after-school job something like that
and then to the point where you're now
an adult and you've got a mortgage in a
car and a
spouse and a dog and all the
responsibilities of life
like i think there is something to say
but hey between you know
17 and 20 or something like that we're
going to do something
you should have some experience in life
away from your family
while you're still maybe dependent a
little bit but also figuring out who you
are and what you want to do and all
those things
so all that being said look i first off
i don't know how you could ever send a
kid to a public school at this point
meaning a public
college right and again i went to state
university of new york this was funded
by the state and it it was relatively
cheap as far as colleges go i think i've
told you this
before i wanted to go to syracuse
because i wanted to be in sports
broadcasting at the time i think it was
about 25 grand
a year um but now it's something like 60
grand a year which is absolutely insane
my dad said hey if you go to a state
school here which they were closer to
like eight grand will pay for it but if
you want to go
to a private school you're gonna have to
pay for the difference and i
i made the decision that i made and i
didn't walk out with debt and then it
helped me going forward
i don't know that any kid should go to
college at this point you know
uh i really don't um i i you're gonna
get brainwashed
you're gonna be mobbed like if you're an
independent thinker all of that stuff's
gonna happen
i would say the more important thing to
do is really like try to i don't know
how you do this exactly as a 17 year old
but
but if you really tried to think about
your life like what kind of person do
you want to be
what what work do you want to do like
what what is it that you enjoy doing if
you can figure
out what that is it's like you can get
an internship
you can get an internship you can get a
low-paying job somewhere
find a mentor you know i talk about this
in in chapter 9 of don't burn this book
my experience with jordan peterson now i
was an adult at that point and it was
sort of an
accidental mentorship because we just
happened to be touring together but like
find someone who's modeling
a life and a and a career
that that's something that you could
aspire to um re look you have
extraordinary power right now if you're
a young person
to like reach out to people that mean
something to you like there's twitter
there's facebook there's ways to message
people
where 20 years ago if you if you liked
an author or you like the
uh whatever it might be you know an
engineer or something is like you have a
very limited way of getting in touch
with them like there's ways to do it now
so and then and then maybe because
they're 17 like i don't know maybe like
go away for a year
like do a year in europe or something
like in just another town something like
that
and by the way of course i would put one
little caveat to all of this which would
be that there are some things you have
to
go to school for say doctors engineers
scientists now we know unfortunately
that social justice is infecting all of
the stem
uh the stem disciplines as well so
there's a issue there for sure uh but
i'm not saying i'm not saying none of it
has any worth
um but if you're going just so that you
can you know major
in you know feminist lesbian badminton
then maybe there's a better way to spend
your money and spend your time no
offense to uh
feminist badminton players uh have you
and david this is from kelly uh always
seen eye to eye politically
have his beliefs and views coincided
with your awakening over the years you
know i've talked about this once or
twice
we've sort of evolved together he was
definitely
a lefty too and we were working together
when i was on the young turks and
you know we yeah we were sort of similar
in that regard we didn't talk about
politics that much in our private lives
like there's other things we like
like food and life and music and having
a good time
um so we were you know i was always sort
of political and he was just kind of
along the ride
on that but i will tell you this that i
when we lived in new york city we've
been together now 10 years
when we lived in new york city um he had
never had a credit card like he didn't
he didn't like believe that you would
ever spend money that you didn't have
like that was something that his dad
taught him
i don't think he taught him not to have
a credit card but like the idea that you
just don't spend money you don't have
his dad's an accountant actually
and and a pretty great guy and so
david could not believe it like when i
was at the time i had some credit card
debt
and he was like i don't understand why
were you spending money if you didn't
have it
and i would be like boy you're you're a
real conservative you're
you know you're fiscally conservative so
in some ways he was sort of ahead of me
on that then i think because we've been
on this voyage together and he's seen
the madness of the left and the hate
that i get for standing up for basic
moderate principles and everything else
we have evolved pretty much
together we have some debates about some
of this stuff
he actually really the only chapter in
in don't burn this book that that i
really took any sort of outside help on
um was we really really got into it on
the abortion
chapter and he really did help me shift
uh some
some stuff over there um and then of
course you know just related to the
abortion thing
um you know we are going through
surrogacy right now and i've mentioned
we've it's
it's been a long uh slog and we've had
some hiccups here and our
we've actually had two uh miscarriages
with our surrogate and we're getting a
new surrogate and i it will work out and
it's
been a stressful year for everybody and
all that stuff um but when you go
through that not only is there just sort
of the emotional toll obviously
finances whatever um but you do learn
about
science right like you do learn oh we've
got a certain amount of embryos here
and we know a day later like they're
male or female they're not like it's
male or female or
other like you do start learning
realities and it's like oh if a day
later
after you put the sperm and the egg
together you got the blastocyst then you
have the embryo a few days after that
it's like they can tell you if it's male
or female it is human
at that point right we would admit
that's a life if it's got a gender
um so some of this stuff has become very
personal to us at the same time
and just i should just say thank you you
know i get a lot of messages like people
with their
sympathy and everything on the um
on the miscarriage side and i know a lot
of people have been through it in this
past year like a lot of people have been
through it a lot of ladies a lot of
women and it goes for the husbands as
well
and uh we're just gonna keep going uh
ian
says are you doing a technology free
month in august
where do you plan on going uh yes i am
doing
august off the grid this will be my
fifth one no phone no tv
no news no current events
the one caveat to that is that i do
occasionally get in my car and there's
gps right in the car and i
pretty much have a horrible sense of
direction so if i'm gonna get anywhere i
will look at a screen there
but that's it like that really really is
it um we did just book a trip i'm going
to shut down we're going to be on a
beach for about 10 days of it
and i'm just going to do nothing i'd
well i'll catch up on reading which
would be nice because you know i've
traveled a lot less
this last year and i used to do most of
my reading on planes um
so i will catch up on some reading but
but not political stuff actually if
you've got
uh any non-fiction like if you've got a
good sci-fi book
or just any just not give me some
non-fiction to deal with
uh i will catch up on reading um i'm not
going to say specifically where we're
going and then we're going to do some
local travel here in california and see
some friends and family
but more of the month is just about like
just honestly it's about clearing my
mind
it's about not staring at that thing i i
really think in these last
five years you know as i've watched so
many people
just sort of lose their minds over
politics and go crazy and be so angry
all the time and really be so
fundamentally different than they were a
couple years ago
i think one of the reasons that i've
managed to stay sane
and on the ball with a lot of this stuff
is because i take this time to
to decompress i take this time to get
off the machines and not be battling
in the matrix all the time right not be
running around and trying to kill all
the agents and have all them kill me and
everything else
so i'm really looking forward to it we
are going to do a huge live stream on
july 30th well
where i will officially announce my next
book
and it will go on pre-sale that day
it'll be out in april and then we've got
a couple other surprises
but yeah i can't i really can't wait i
really can't wait uh
ben says a few weeks ago victoria's
secret went woke as a fellow seinfeld
fan you might know
where i'm going with this how long until
the bro
man's ear becomes a real thing so for
those of you that are not
seinfeld fans what he's referring to is
that episode where frank stanza
and kramer they uh meet up with a former
colleague of frankissanzes i believe his
name is uh
sid farkas he's a bra salesman and
what frankistanza wants is he wants a
bro or a man's ear basically a man's bra
because he's you know he's got a little
heft in the chest area
we're definitely making a gif of this
okay
and and then all sorts of hijinks go
from there sid farkas then tries to make
a move on estelle frank's wife
it's a whole situation um but your
question is how long basically
until a victoria's secret is making bras
for men
i give it a year i give it a year like
panties for men bras for men
lace panties crotchless the whole all of
these things they they
just woke this you let it in it will
destroy
your company your organization your
family
and your life that's how it is sid
farkas great reference
marissa says there are millions being
forced out of their communities
because they're being priced out of the
market
given the craze in the housing market
what are your thoughts on how long it'll
take
for it to come back to reality i love
this question because the housing market
is insane almost everywhere so i was in
miami a couple weeks ago
and i met with mayor francis suarez of
miami
i hope you guys have seen the episode
already we shot that on location in
miami beach and then i met
with the mayor of battle harbor
obviously
bell harbor is very close to seaside
where they're dealing with everything
that happened
with that building collapse but really
really really great guy
and anyway i talked to a whole bunch of
people in miami and because we're moving
locals down there and my
my sister just moved down there and my
brother-in-law like talking about real
estate and it's it's absolutely crazy
all over florida but miami specifically
but i can tell you this even here in los
angeles the market is nuts
i have a very good friend who is one of
the top real estate agents in los
angeles
and she's been telling me how none of it
makes sense it actually doesn't make
sense there is so
little inventory right now even though
tons of people are leaving how the
prices are just
incredibly high right now you put
something for sale it gets sold
immediately
now there's there's some reasons for
this you know there was this big
article written about how blackwater is
buying up all these homes
and how banks are buying up homes and
you know mortgage rates still
are low at least for now so you know
people can get loans more easily
but this idea that basically
private companies are going to buy
houses and that sort of the middle class
will just become permanent renters
is one of the most scary ideas being
floated right now
you know this sort of you will own
nothing but you will be happy idea
it's a really scary thing you know if
i've done one thing right
financially over the last couple years
it's that we went a little over our head
on our first house where my old studio
was like we stretched
because i believed in owning a thing my
my whole philosophy was if i own a
physical thing
i can do additions to that thing i can
put work into that thing
and if i'm living in it i like paying
mortgage believe it or not like i don't
mind paying the mortgage because
interest rates are so low
to me it's like you're just paying
yourself like you're yeah there's a
little bit of interest there
but every month when when i write that
check or it's done electronically now
it's like oh i don't feel like i'm
giving
that money away it's money so that i
have equity in my home which is a thing
um so we went over on that house we went
over on this house
and i believe that that's good like if
you own a physical thing
then you can move up the ladder so the
fact that they're taking this away now
from the middle class
is very is very very dangerous and it's
weird because even in a place like san
francisco where we know so many people
are leaving and as you guys know
california had the first net drop of
population ever this year and it's in
the history of the state
it's like you would think the housing
market would be collapsing and it's not
so this is one of those like artificial
bubble situations and can it last
forever well
usually bubbles do burst uh peter
says what was the your favorite thing
you did over the fourth of july weekend
well we did
a crazy amount of grilling and i had my
sister and
my brother-in-law and their kids here
and we had some other friends over
but my favorite thing we did an
impromptu out of nowhere
saturday trip to uh universal studios
uh we lived about 20 minutes away from
universal and i had my six-year-old
niece here my three-year-old nephew and
we had just watched harry potter
with my niece we watched like three the
first three and then we took her to
harry potter land and we got her a wand
and she got to
you know you could if you get the wand
you can stand on a thing and you wave
your wand and some stuff happens
and we had some butter beer uh and we
went on a couple of the rides
and it was just like i've been to
universal a gajillion times because most
of my family doesn't live in california
so everyone when they come to california
they want to do the the
universal thing they want to do the
disney thing um
you know they've got the transformers
ride there and they just updated the
jurassic park ride is now the jurassic
world ride and
a bunch of other stuff it was just a fun
day like yeah i've done the studio tour
a million times and jaws is still there
and you know they got the the earthquake
situation with the flood it's like they
haven't changed a lot of it in 30 years
or whatever it is
um but you know it's especially if
you're with kids and you can kind of see
it through their eyes and it's like
you know watching my niece with the wand
and like oh we were
just at hogwarts we were just watching
hogwarts on tv last night and now we're
in the castle where you could take the
tour
uh that's what it's all about uh
anderson says how do you how long do you
think
uh joe j.o biden
is going to last um i mean it's the
million-dollar question it's like
it's like right now we see him
sputtering
everyone gets it right i don't need to
belabor the point like
even even people that won't talk about
it publicly privately
are acknowledging something ain't right
there so the question is can they
you know push this thing i mean they've
got about three years that they still
need to get this guy to the end of this
thing
will they have to hide him more will
they have to drug him more like
i don't know i don't know my guess might
just
my guess is because it does seem
significantly worse
than it was even a few months ago is
that he doesn't make it the whole time
that they will announce some sort of
medical thing or something like that
and kamala will take over that that
would be my guess
uh but i but it's fairly obvious that
the hope
by the biden administration or the obama
people or the clinton people whatever
that thing is
and nobody knows what that thing is at
this point or very few people i should
say know what it is
um the hope obviously is that he gets to
the end of the term and then and then
you run kamala or are they just gonna
sandbag her
and and put in somebody else who the
hell knows but i don't think
my gut feeling is it won't last the
entire time but who knows
mike says there have been several states
or parts of states that have been
discussing
secession do you believe it's all talk
or is there a possibility that states
may change their boundaries or the u.s
might eventually
split up you know there is a decent
amount of rumble
and talk about this online you know i
know that there are some cities
up in the oregon area that want to that
want to secede and
you know people talk about a changing
map and that the red and the blue
are really becoming so deeply different
which as i always say in some ways
that's kind of good that's what
federalism is
but at some level if the idea is oh we
can have sort of
free you know free market capitalists
uh truly american states versus these
sort of
marxist communist states like what is
the thing that ties us together what is
the united states part
and i don't know what that would be so
on one hand i'm actually okay with
people leaving cali to go to florida and
i talk about the foot vote all the time
and the other hand it's like if that
keeps going and going and going like
what is the uniter like if the uniter is
not
the united states if the uniter is not
the constitution is the uniter if the
uniters not we have some cultural
identity that brings us together
then a split may be inevitable so it's
one of those things that i don't really
like talking about because i think
in some ways if you talk about it you
start giving it more energy and people
get that idea there and then and then
and then it just by entropy it almost
will happen
on the other hand maybe we do have to
figure out some of this stuff because as
i as i always talk about if
we those of you that are watching this
that are somewhat like-minded
if our basic set of ideas is that we
just
want to be left alone that's one thing
but if their basic set of ideas is they
don't want to leave us alone
that's really an intractable problem
like i don't really know what you do
with that
and and maybe maybe a breakup is the
best thing
it's a tough one it's a really tough one
uh tabitha says with low
uh will locals be hiring for
administrative financial and hr roles
soon yes
absolutely i know for sure on the hr
side i don't know if the job posting is
up yet
but locals.com jobs and
although we are really looking to hire
people in miami right now because we're
opening the office there
it'll be our third office actually we
have two in europe right now um
we you know we're willing to talk to you
if you don't live in miami just yet or
if you don't live in florida just yet
like if you're a good engineer or you're
a great administrator you've got a great
financial background
uh you're great at human resources
whatever it may be we we would consider
it so jobs
at locals no locals.com
jobs i should say and uh and by the way
i am going to miami this evening for a
big meeting tomorrow
i can say no more storm says is there
any government agency that you believe
is doing good or have they all corroded
that's a good one is there any
government agency that you believe is
doing good well first off i would say
there absolutely are good people who
work at these
agencies right like i think that most of
law enforcement
are good people i think most of the
people that are trying to protect our
borders
are good people i think i i would even
take things like you know
the board of education you know like the
basic
the department of education you know
like are there good people who work at
the department of education there's got
to be a couple good people there right
like i don't think they're all
sort of crazed marxists but a lot of
them and the and the sort of glue that
holds these things together has been
infected right
so is there any government agency you
believe is doing good
like probably not well i guess
look we aren't being overrun by zombies
at our borders right we've got a border
problem but like
we're not being completely overrun so
that's pretty decent so i would say that
there's
there's there's some decent stuff there
and i would always stand by the good
people
there um but it may just be that the
the systems in place are just too
corroded but yeah like to me you could
blow up the department of education what
do
what do we need it for uh maybe we have
to really look at the department of
defense and see like
it seems pretty woke right now like we
got a problem there like
we could probably blow up most of these
things should we look at the department
of energy
and it's like are we are we really doing
the right things the department of
transportation i know we got gay pete in
charge
but like should we look at what's going
on there while he's telling us that
roads are racist and everything else
it's like
who knows uh janet says any 2021 tv
show or movie recommendations you know
just last night
we watched on amazon prime the tomorrow
war
with chris pratt and it was actually
pretty decent
movies have become so bad and i would
say almost everything on netflix and all
this stuff because woke-ism just
destroys everything
it's impossible to create anything good
and everything else
but we watch the tomorrow war it stars
chris pratt and i believe he directed it
did he direct it also
tomorrow or chris pratt i think he did
uh he didn't direct it no but he did he
co-write it he did or he produced it i
think at least something yeah
he produced it i got a thumbs up um it
wasn't woke
it was sci-fi it was futurey it was a
little scary
it made you think it wasn't the greatest
movie i've ever seen
but the aliens were kind of cool and
different and it had like
you know some heart pumping action in it
it was actually a movie
worth watching uh on television not much
you know we just watched the third
season of the kaminsky method on
netflix which was michael douglas and
alan arkin
really two of the greatest actors of the
last like 50 years it's three seasons
the first two seasons were spectacular
and then i'm guessing that alan arkin i
think he's
like late 80s maybe even 90 at this
point he didn't do the last season
so i don't know if it was because a
covet or some other reason didn't do it
and the show just completely derailed in
the third season but if you want to
watch this sort of like a
sort of quick just like a light fun
funny show about
about aging and you know coming to terms
with your life and everything else the
first two seasons of the kaminsky method
on netflix were
quite good last question candice says do
you think trump has a real chance
against those goons at facebook twitter
and google so if you didn't see this
trump announced yesterday a class action
lawsuit
against twitter facebook and google and
including some of the ceos of those
companies i believe zuckerberg was
personally mentioned jack dorsey
over at twitter you know i saw an
interview with alan dershowitz
famed harvard law professor who's been
right about most of the issues and he
takes the hits for it
and he said this is the most important
first amendment case in modern times
so if alan dershowitz is going that deep
on it i think obviously the case has
some merit you know there's the endless
debate over section 230 of the
communications act
whether these are platforms or
publishers how they treat information
meaning are they censoring people and if
they are they're not platforms they're
actual publishers
in which case they should be held liable
on the other hand if you hold facebook
and twitter liable for the content
that's on their
platforms they they might start
censoring more so these are not easy
things to deal with but
i will say this i think it's good
even if trump loses the lawsuit the idea
that there is now a legitimate class
action lawsuit
and by the way class action that means
anyone can get in on this that's using
these services right trump is just
the lead person on the on the suit well
the idea that he's going to sue them and
has some money to do it
like maybe they're going to have to open
up some of the secrets right maybe
they're
gonna you know because of discovery
twitter is gonna have to be like oh we
did have employees you know looking at
your direct messages
and we actually were shadow banning
based on political belief
oh and you know now there's suddenly
some leaked emails and it turns out when
we decided to blow up
trump's twitter account it turns out
that you know eight of the ten people
that did it
were also donating to the biden campaign
like who knows who knows what we will
find out but the general idea
of a lawsuit to get a little more
accountability from these companies even
if ultimately the lawsuit loses i think
that's pretty good but as you know i
always say
you know probably some anti-trust stuff
where you break them up and more than
anything else
competition man that is what will save
us uh guys i
am heading to miami tonight so later
today we're actually pre-taping
tomorrow's uh round table uh which will
be a weekly recap of
all of the madness uh with walter kern
who i've never had on the show before
who i've wanted to have on for every
screenwriter
really brilliant guy i do gutfeld's show
with him often and he's just like a
truly
unique political thinker if you don't
know him so i'm really happy we're
having him on
carlin borisenko who we've had on many
times she was once a lefty
knitter then she went to a trump rally
and became a complete right-wing maniac
like me who knew
uh and viva fry one of my favorite legal
experts
from the uh country formerly known as
canada that now seems to be
a dystopian nightmare also guys part two
of my interview with jd vance who's
running for
senate in ohio is up right now and of
course the full episode is already
up ad free at reubenreport.locals.com
all right i got a couple other things
to do and then i'm hopping on a plane to
miami maybe we'll try to do a meet-up
there but it's going to be a pretty uh
a pretty wacky trip but if you want to
at least
see if there's a meetup reuben
report.locals.com all right have a great
day everybody
and i'll i'll see well you'll see me
tomorrow i'll see you on monday